I hope our discussion of the big problems in AI didn't scare you off,
let's bring the discussion down, closer to work.
And talk about a few fundamental characteristics of AI problems. Number one,
in many AI problems, data arrives incrementally not all the data comes
right at the beginning. Number two, problems often have a recurring pattern,
the same kinds of problems occur again and again. Number three,
problems occur at many different levels of abstraction. Problem number four,
many interesting AI problems are computationally intractable. Number five,
the world is dynamic, it's constantly changing but knowledge of
the world is relative to static. Number six, the world is open ended but
knowledge of the world is relatively limited. So, the question then becomes,
how can we design air agents that can address air problems with
these characteristics, those are the challenges we'll discuss in this course